là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène à un peu moins que
mais si vous ne réussissez pas ce qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose un tout
petit détail le trophée les valises à
paris qu'est ce qu'il lui arrive à la
bleue
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine c'est l'inattendu et vous
êtes les bienvenus à mes côtés géraldine
corner lavaud et camille d'auxerre
journaliste à la rédaction nina bonjour
à toutes les deux alors qu'amy vous avez
un anniversaire à souhaiter oui et pas
n'importe quel anniversaire on souffle
une centenaire les santons de la salle
de cinéma le louxor dans le nord de
paris très sympa une salle inscrits au
titre des monuments historiques parce
que le louxor et bien c'est une
décoration un peu à part très art déco
largement inspirée par l'egypte antique
et puis surtout c'est une survivante
elle a été ouvert donc le 6 octobre
1921 a très longtemps été fermée a même
échappé à la destruction mais en 2013
résurrection grâce à la mairie de paris
la salle de cinéma rouvre et dont les
archives en 1985 voici comment on
décrivait cette mythique salle un temple
qui émerveille
délibérément exotique on le dit egypte
10 ans mais il est de partout il se
nourrit de tout et il convient à tous
un temple qui tient le coup depuis 60
ans et plus
pas besoin de ciment pour tenir
l'édifice il faut juste des larmes des
baisers et du sens c'est bien des
archers de 85 tout à fait danse a un
petit côté un petit peu plus fameux oui
ils ont patiné un peu l'image
alors vous géraldine vous souhaitiez
revenir sur le décès de bernard tapie
oui un bernard tapie enterré à marseille
où une chapelle ardente au stade
vélodrome on croule ici à linas où les
archives concernant bernard tapie mais
je voulais vous montrer une interview en
particulier celle de 2006 sur le plateau
de tout le monde en parle regardez
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre à crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même vrai juste
avant de partir et d'avoir un il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont pas soulevés
encore et encore de 3 bourre pif dans
l'airé ouais il ya 2-3 y ait une tournée
à faire qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire
de plus négatif sur vous
et tu crois pas qu'il en a été si dit
comme ça sans
moi j'ai été gâté quand même
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
bonjour away enterré incinérés un vrai
qu'on l'enterré vivant comme en descente
les a non non je m'en fous sagement
complète
j'ai pas peur de ça du tout je suis
croyant
j'ai pas fait trop de mal contrairement
à ce qu'on a dit a pas tellement de gens
qui ont souffert et donc à la fin du
parcours je pense qu'ils me dire allez
viens il était temps que tu arrives
voilà c'est vrai ce quotidien c'est
drôle à dire qu'elle à l'humour de
baffie et la répartie d'un art tapis
voilà donc pour l'actualité de cette
semaine que s'est il passé à cette même
période de l'année par le passé mais
pour le savoir je vous propose de
regarder le zapping de l'inattendu
bonjour
le 4 octobre 1957 marquera probablement
pour les temps fut dur les débuts de
l'ère interplanétaire c'est en effet ce
jour que les russes eux choisir pour
envoyer spoutnik 1 le premier satellite
artificiel de la terre c'est donc la
surprise de la matinée le prix nobel de
la paix a été attribué à barack obama le
président américain a été récompensé
pour ses efforts diplomatiques
il recevra son prix le 10 décembre
prochain à oslo
ici nous avons une vraie démocratie et
nous avons gagné dans la légalité au
revoir les perdants
ce qui restera dorsaux noël c'est aussi
l'image d'un colosse truculent qui a
occupé une large place dès le début de
sa carrière dans l'histoire du cinéma
à présent tout cas la population ignore
dans sa grande majorité des événements
qui se déroulent sur des fronts du
proche orient depuis le début de l'après
midi ça n'a communiqué ni terry bien
déclare que l'armée a traversé le canal
de suez en plusieurs points
jacques brel est mort vous savez tous
maintenant ce matin à l'âge de 49 ans
des suites d'un cancer du poumon
[Musique]
bonsoir et à denain
les intempéries exceptionnelles observé
ces derniers jours après plus d'une
semaine de grève des poubelles à
marseille provoque une catastrophe
écologique à des déchets partout
charrier vers la mer des déchets qui
obstruent les évacuations de l'eau dans
la ville marçais qui croule sous les
déchets géraldine et c'est loin d'être
la première fois effectivement les
premières grèves médiatisée au plan
national remonte aux années soixante dix
à marseille on peut le voir sur les
images depuis dans la cité phocéenne le
sujet du ramassage des ordures est
toujours resté un point extrêmement
sensible regardez ce sujet rendez avec
les rares voix la liberté
a ras-le-bol c'est une fois par mois
alors à marseille les poubelles qui
débordent c'est une histoire sans fin
c'est pas des rats c'est à dire après
c'était battre
c'est un désastre c'est tout ni plus ni
moins
ça devient et jus pur talent entre 1976
et 2010 il y a eu 14 grève de plus de 4
jours les poubelles elle allait bel
plein et l'erreur qui sortent de partout
franchement c'est une honte les raisons
de faire grève sont multiples contre des
réformes du secteur public ou des
réformes nationales comme en 2003 10 des
16 arrondissements de marseille envahie
par les ordures et cela va durer force
ouvrière en tête les syndicats
d'éboueurs ont entamé un mouvement de
grève illimitée pour protester contre le
projet de réforme des retraites mais
aussi et c'est bien spécifique à
marseille à chaque renouvellement de
marché des acteurs privés en effet un
tiers de la collecte est géré par des
entreprises privées et à chaque nouvel
appel d'offres tous les six ans les
coûts sont tirés vers le bas et la
grogne monte exemple avec l'appel à la
grève illimitée de 1993 faire ramasser
par un homme seul sur un marche pied des
moyennes de 15 à 18 tonnes par jour
c'est détruire un bonhomme les sociétés
privées font ça parce que tous les six
ans elle repasse un marché elles font
cadeau à la sécurité sociale de leurs
vieux gars et de lorgues a détruit et
elle ré embauche des jeunes exactement
les mêmes revendications six ans plus
tard en 1999 la source du problème c'est
que les marchés sont passés de façon à
obtenir des coups les pubs sans regarder
la qualité offerte le bras de fer entre
les éboueurs très syndiqués et la
municipalité et à chaque fois féroce à
tel point que les maires font appel à
l'armée exemple en 1976 quand j'ai vu la
lure que prenaient les choses et de dire
la chaleur torride
l'accumulent mans des ordures ménagères
je me suis rappelé qu' il ya deux ans il
ya été amassé plusieurs cas de choléra
serait pas le droit
d'accepter une situation pareille pour
marseille j'ai leur signer une
convention avec l'armée pour avoir la
certitude que quoi qu'il arrive et
malgré les menaces des éléments de jeu
price vous avais je parlais tout à
l'heure je dois m'en serais bien fait à
marseille aujourd'hui et bien c'est fait
1999 autre mère mais même solution j'ai
donc demandé à monsieur le préfet des
bouches du rhône qui m'a donné son
accord qui à partir de lundi matin
l'armée interviendra dans le xiiième et
xivème arrondissement pour enlever les
ordures ménagères donc ces poubelles qui
débordent à marseille ça a donné une
réputation à cette ville de ville un peu
crade un pas vraiment reluisant comme
comme réputation pourtant petites
archives bonus en 1965 gaston defferre
qu'on a déjà vu dans le sujet 1 figure
de marseille maire de 1953 à 1986 avait
un voeu pieux pour cette ville nous
avons décidé monsieur castellina qui est
beau notre joie au tam et moi même de
faire de mars est une des villes les
plus propres de france devions déjà
accomplir et grands efforts dans ce
domaine nous entendons maintenant
poursuivre et amplifier cet exposé cet
effort pour cela
des poubelles ont été distribués mais
nous sommes obligés de reconnaître que
les marseillais n'aime pas beaucoup ce
servir de poubelle
les marseillais qui n'aime pas se servir
de poubelle en 65 ça il reste quand même
une ville merveilleuse exactement
merveilleuse effectivement mais
marseille la ville la plus propre de
france ça en revanche très loin merci
beaucoup géraldine merci
[Musique]
l'église une nouvelle fois montré du
doigt pour le comportement de certains
religieux le très attendu rapport de la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église vient d'être rendu
public un rapport de 2500 pages
commandée par l'église elle même plus de
6500 témoignages ont été recueillis en
deux ans et demi pour faire un état des
lieux des agressions en 70 ans deux cent
seize mille victimes d'abus sexuels
commis par des prêtres ou des religieux
330 milles en comptant les victimes de
laïcs travaillant dans les institutions
de l'église pour en parler nous recevons
christine pedotti directrice de la revue
témoignage chrétien auteur d'un ouvrage
consacré à la question qu'avez vous fait
de jésus c'est aux éditions albin michel
alors bonjour christine pedotti vous
faites partie des personnes auditionnées
par cette commission j'aimerais savoir
si vous êtes surprise par le résultat
tout le monde est surpris par l'ampleur
parce que finalement la commission sauvé
a fait un travail sur la population
générale c'était un travail statistique
au delà de l'identification des victimes
qui ont accepté de parler il ya un
échantillon sur la population générale
et donc ils obtiennent des chiffres que
aucune autre grande commission et y en a
eu d'autres y en a eus aux états unis il
y en a eu en australie il y en a eu en
allemagne aucune autre grande commission
avait fait ce travail là donc là on a
des chiffres qui sont proprement
stupéfiants stupéfiants accablant
sidérant tous les mots sont là pour dire
qu'en fait on en a les clés et genou qui
s'incline n'ayant faudra peut-être se
mettre à genoux fera peut-être les
élèves se mettent à genoux pour demander
pardon parce que quand même c'était eux
qui étaient leur job c'était de faire en
sorte que ça n'arrive pas alors kabyle
quant à tout commençait à
et vu ok cc violence à la télévision
bien dans les années 90 et ça commence
aux etats unis des milliers de plaintes
sont déposées le pape jean paul ii s'en
émeut dans une lettre il autorise les
cardinaux a sanctionné les prêtres
pédophiles mais ça c'est uniquement sur
le papier si j'ose dire et chez nous en
france les langues se délient les
victimes parlent la télévision sont fait
l'écho dans les années 90 à l'époque
donc les victimes parlent à visage
découvert mais nous nous avons choisi de
flouter leurs visages possédé par le
démon de midi le curé reconnaît avoir eu
dans ces circonstances des gestes
déplacés envers ses enfants qui relate
les faits à leurs parents
stupeur dans le canton de saint romain
de colbosc que la population a appris ce
matin l'arrestation de son curé l'abbé
cardon l'ecclésiastique âgé de 63 ans se
serait livré à des attouchements sur des
enfants l'abbé vincent a passé sa
première nuit en prison depuis 37 ans ce
prêtre très connu et très apprécié des
meusiens dirigé la chorale diocésaine
des petits chanteurs de bar le duc
aujourd'hui la baie est mis en examen
pour viols et agressions sexuelles sur
mineurs
christine pedotti qu'est ce qui explique
ce tournant dans les années 90 pourquoi
subitement on s'est mis à parler de ces
affaires ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis a été très important parce que
c'est là où on fait ça commence à parler
au fond il faut que les victimes parlent
vous rendre compte que ces abus c'est le
silence qui est qui la cause principale
et ça veut dire qu'en fait du point de
vue des enfants il ya quelque chose
d'indicible cird impossible à dire et de
la part des leurs parents des éducateurs
etc il ya quelque chose qui ne peut pas
être compris pourquoi parce que les
prêtres il normalement c'est des hommes
sans sexualité
puisqu'ils font voeu de deux jeux de
chasteté donc en fait arrivés à penser
que le curé a eu des gestes déplacés à
l'égard d'un enfant via les processus ni
sont très très importants ils sont très
important aussi parce que le prêtre
c'est un peu c'est dieu qui parle quand
il n'ouvre la bouche donc en fait on va
d'abord avoir tendance à croire on
ad'abord toujours tendance à croire les
adultes est pas les enfants et donc
quand en plus l'adulte il parle comme
s'il était dieu lui-même évidemment le
croit donc on a dit et on a des
témoignages abondent en de gosse qui a
dit on dit monsieur le curé m'a pris sur
les genoux et à qui ils ont reçu une
tarte de la part des parents en disant
arrête de raconter des aurores et ses
victimes deux hommes d'église elle nous
rappelle forcément les victimes
d'inceste aussi dans la famille comme à
l'église c'est difficile de dénoncer le
père bien sûr c'est d'ailleurs à mon
avis ce qui fait qu'on voit une
prévalence c'est à dire une grande
quantité d'abus dans l'église parce que
ça fonctionne comme une famille c'est à
dire que nous avons la figure du père
qui est abuseurs la figure de la mère
c'est l'église qui est silencieuse et
puis c'est les enfants qui trinquent
c'est exactement comme dans une famille
c'est le triangle incestueux de la
famille qui est à l'oeuvre dans l'église
alors si si les dénonciations commence
dans les années 90 avec convient de voir
un des reportages tout le monde en
revanche n'est pas prêt à les entendre
un câble oui exactement
certaines victimes parlent mais le
clergé les hommes d'église ne sont pas
tous prêts à les écouter à les entendre
exemple en 1994 en bourgogne avec
françoise cabaye et elle est directrice
d'un collège privé catholique et elle
découvre dans un tiroir des
photographies des montages
pornographiques impliquant des élèves du
collège elle dénonce réponse de sa
hiérarchie qui est le diocèse elle est
licenciée l'été dernier elle trouve dans
un tiroir de l'école un lot de photos
pédophiles impliquant des élèves de
l'établissement
françoise cabale et les transmet à une
association de parents d'élèves contre
l'avis de sa hiérarchie
justement parce que j'ai choisi
l'enseignement catholique j'estime que
mon devoir est de dénoncer qui doit être
dénoncé quand cela se présente et en
2019 françois ce qu'elle valait revenait
sur cet événement devant les caméras de
l'ina des faits similaires dénoncé
aujourd'hui
ne s'inscrirait pas dans le même
contexte il y à 25 ans et
j'étais dans une situation de pot de
terre rencontrant un pot de fer ma
parole pesait bien peu
dans un contexte d' omerta alors en 2019
le diocèse réaffirmé que son
licenciement n'avait rien à voir avec
cette affaire cela étant dit peau terre
contre pot de fer est ce que les mots
sont justes est-ce que s'attaquer à
l'église c'est perdu d'avancé alors non
c'est pas perdu d'avancé d'ailleurs la
preuve c'est que finalement nous avons
ce rapport est que au bout du compte les
évêques après avoir je dirais dit que au
fond c'était quelques brebis galeuses
que c'était quelques pommes pourries et
cetera ont fini sous la pression voilà
puis participer à cette pression
d'ailleurs puissance de la vie ce n'est
plus la même aujourd'hui la même de
revêtent on a dit ben on veut savoir la
vérité parce qu'au fond il ya trois ans
encore 3 encore quand on interrogeait
les évêques qui nous disaient oui enfin
il ya 3 30 ou 40 cas ils sont identifiés
on les a vus externe on n'est pas à 30
ou 40 l'a2 d'abuseurs aujourd'hui on
reconnaît jusqu'à 3000 cas à mon avis on
est plutôt en dessous de la vérité 1
parce que là on n'a pas de moyens
statistiques les habits on a ce chiffre
monstrueux de deux cent seize mille
victimes ce qui est absolument colossale
après ce crime se lance vraiment ccc oui
c'est monstrueux c'est qu'il ya sur 70
ans avant alors avant de chercher avant
ne sait rien avant on ne sait absolument
rien il faut lire le problème aussi
c'est que il ya dans le catholicisme
d'ailleurs le rapport sauvé de 10 il ya
des choses qui sort qu'ils sont qui en
fait le maire t'as quand on est ouverte
à tous et pas seulement une institution
qui se défend c'est vraiment une
institution qui qui a du mal à parler de
la sexualité parce que la sexualité elle
existe seulement entre un homme et d'une
femme dans le cadre du mariage tout le
reste est du péché alors après les
hiérarchies dans le péché mais non mais
s'attaquent à des enfants ce n'est pas
un pêché c'est un crime c'est quand même
pas la même chose et ça on a beaucoup de
mal à le penser et puis
ils ont je suis obligé de dire il parce
que le fait que ce soit des hommes est
exclusivement des hommes 1 je peux pas
je peux pas utiliser un langage inclusif
pour
de base ils ont l'idée quand même que
ils ont une sorte de mission qui leur
vient de dieu qu'il ya une sacralité et
que du coup je dire ils sont un peu au
dessus des autres
alors bon le curé il dit aux enfants bah
c'est un secret entre toi et moi mais
quand le curé dit c'est un secret entre
toi et moi l'enfant il est coincé par ce
secret il est emprisonné d'ailleurs
quand on écoute les victimes il parle de
prison il dit nous sommes en prison les
victimes disent qu'elles sont
emprisonnés par ce silence depuis des
dizaines d'années on a aussi des cas
proprement sidérant de gens qui se
rendent compte alors qu'ils ont 50 ans
qu'en fait le malheur est le malaise
qu'ils éprouvent depuis tant d'années il
est lié à cet abus donc il ya déjà des
capacités d'occultation de refoulement
enfin voilà il ya des tas de mécanismes
qui sont en jeu là dedans alors
justement il ya une affaire qui va
marquer l'opinion publique camille
n'avait plus que les autres oui c'est la
sphère piquant en
1998 cet évêque pierre pican à cacher
des viols et des agressions sexuelles
d'un des prêtres de son diocèse la baby
c'est lui que vous voyez il est condamné
à 18 ans de réclusion criminelle pour
s'en être pris à onze jeunes garçons et
au lieu de le dénoncer monseigneur
piquant l'a envoyée dans une autre
paroisse comme on le faisait très
régulièrement les familles des victimes
décident de le poursuivre pour non
dénonciation lui il avance le secret de
la confession mais il écope de trois
mois de prison avec sursis une première
condamnation en france pour ne pourra
plus se retrancher derrière le secret
professionnel pour s'abstenir de
dénoncer des faits graves de viols
commis sur des enfants mineurs
monseigneur piquant est reparti sans
avoir fait le moindre commentaire sur sa
condamnation une condamnation qui
constitue une première juridique en
france et qui intervient dans un climat
de suspicion autour de l'église et ses
membres de plus en plus lourd les
membres du clergé ne peuvent donc plus
se cacher derrière le secret de la
confession comme un médecin avec son
patient est ce que l'église a eu là
réponse adéquate après ce procès alors
clairement la sphère piquant c'est une
sorte de coup de tonnerre moi j'ai bien
vu à ce moment là les évêques
dans leur réunion plénière à lourdes qui
suit il écoute des sociologues des
psychologues qui leur explique ce que
c'est illicite et rallo et tombe de
l'armoire il savait pas qu ils
découvrent ils découvrent il découvre
surtout la blessure des enfants parce
que ils vont se dire mais non mais en
fait c'étaient des enfants ce pas si
grave que ça les enfants
cc voilà il ya de la capacité de
résilience enfin on l'entend encore à le
cardinal barbarin en novembre 2018 il
dit encore on croyait que les enfants ça
rebondisse est sidérant du coup les
évêques là il ya qui comprennent quelque
chose ou moins quelques-uns en
l'occurrence cardinal barbarin qui n'est
pas encore cardinal et leur temps du ca
mais visiblement elle n'est pas tout
compris mais enfin bon je suis difficile
à comprendre et puis donc ils disent bon
maintenant c'est tolérance zéro on va
faire des choses et c'est visiblement ça
ne marche pas complètement dire là on
est à l'étape d'après on est vingt ans
plus tard et
c'est là aussi où les gens disent
attendait les bonnes résolutions ça va
bien alors il ya aussi une parole qui
est intéressante à main sur ccsl celle
des papin jean paul ii a condamné ces
crimes benoît 16 a présenté des excuses
idem pour le pape françois qui en a
appelé à la justice des hommes est-ce
que ça a plu à tout le monde au sein de
l'église que la justice des hommes
prennent le pas ainsi sur celle de dieu
alors il faut savoir que dans l'histoire
de l'église l'idée que l'éclair puisse
être jugé par la justice ordinaire
c'est quelque chose à une chose à
laquelle l'église s'est opposé pendant
des siècles considérant qu' il exerçait
la justice eux-mêmes et donc en fait
quand on a des siècles pendant
lesquelles on considère que la seule
justice qui doit juger lé clair c'est la
justice ecclésiastique et on a du mal à
s'en sortir et encore aujourd'hui c'est
toujours concédé un peu du bout des
lèvres ça fait des années qu'il ya une
pression quand même sur l'église vous en
2018 avec témoignage chrétien vous aviez
appelé à une commission d' enquête
parlementaire pourquoi alors mieux vaut
tard que jamais mais pourquoi l'église a
mis tant de temps
parce que tout le monde est dans le déni
parce que tout le monde voudrait bien
que ça passe à côté enfin même encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'aujourd'hui 1 je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'évêques qui se
disent on va faire le gros dos on va
attendre que la laque passé qui on va
reprendre on va retourner à notre vrai
boulot comme ça votre camp oui non mais
c'est clairement faire l'autruche il ya
vraiment de ça et je dire il a fallu
littéralement qu'on leur torde le bras
pour qu'on obtienne cette commission
donc il va falloir continuer pour qu' il
y ait des réformes dans l'église sous
réserve que ya encore de suffisamment de
gens qu'ils soient intéressés par ce qui
se passe dans l'église catholique pour
avoir envie de se battre une dernière
archives camille avec un témoignage
celui n'offrait oui on est en 2010
témoignage très fort d'un prêtre qui se
confesse en quelque sorte anonyme en
face aux caméras il a été condamné pour
agression sexuelle
j'ai eu une première relation avec un
jeune
les prêts ne sont pas des anges
si nous étions asexué ça se saurait et
il ya forcément ce cette tension qu'il
ya entre les voeux que nous avons
prononcé aux journaux ordination et puis
la réalité et puis les tentations du
quotidien je le répète que ce soit
envers une femme que ce soit envers un
homme
où que ce soit envers un
jeune garçon ou une jeune fille enfin
peu importe un jour pourtant il choisit
d'en parler un évêque dans le secret du
confessionnal
la seule réponse qui devrait donner
s'est battue n'a qu'à prendre une douche
froide ça passera ces glaçons presque ce
qu'il dit ce prêtre d'abord la douche
froide quand on quand il avoue avoir
commis des atteintes sexuelles à un
enfant et puis son constat aussi les
prêtres ne sont pas à sexuée alors
certains diront est-ce qu'il faut mettre
un terme au célibat
et
c'est une des grandes questions
il me semble qu il y a un problème aussi
dans le fait que c'est le célibat gay
passe temps choisi que le problème en
fait il est il est pas vraiment choisi
célibat façon pour être prêtre il faut
être célibataire aujourd'hui dans le
catholicisme il n'y a pas le choix
c'est une vraie question c'est une
question qu'il faut poser
moi quand j'écoute en plus il dit oui
alors on peut être attiré on a dit + 20
par un homme par une femme par un enfant
c'est pas la même chose et
on voit bien même à travers cette phrase
à quel point les quelque chose de
pervers dont l'arabe dans le rapport à
la sexualité
le rapport à la sexualité c'est un
adulte qui désirent un adulte c'est pas
un adulte qui désirent un enfant fin ça
il ya quelque chose de
c'est pas juste pas normal et ya encore
beaucoup de questions même à l'issue de
la publication de ce rapport tenez pour
terminer un récent sondage ifop montre
que 51% des français se déclarent non
croyants ils étaient 43 % en 2011 alors
est ce que vous craignez que ce rapport
éloigne encore un petit peu plus
certaines personnes de l'église oui
indiscutablement parce que c'est quoi le
métier l'église à l'église de temps
danger oui bien sûr que l'église est en
danger et gravement en danger le métier
de l'hélice et c'est en fait d'être cru
sur parole
il ya son métier c'est d'annoncer une
parole qui dit venir de dieu si on la
croit pas parce que sa parole est
toujours frappé de mensonges de
dissimulations entre les terrains puis
déjà tout d'un coup elle est privée de
parole et quand elle est privée de
parole c'est comme si elles n'existaient
plus
christine pedotti directrice de la revue
témoignage chrétien auteur du livre
qu'avez vous fait de jésus chez albin
michel merci à vous pour ses
explications et merci avocat me pour ce
travail on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine toujours sur le canal 27 et en
attendant sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ce dîner ou ce de france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes florence lui c'est aimer
en gala thomas de gent merci à eux et
merci à vous d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]